You may have heard that money can't always buy happiness. Well, that's especially true for children from affluent families who may feel pressure to succeed, get good grades, and be modeled children. In this episode, we talk with one psychologist who is teaching her own children how to be happy without relying on money. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Sunil Luther is a psychology professor at Arizona State University. She has studied the vulnerability and resilience of youth in poverty and children. and families affected by mental illness. Her most recent work has focused on children in affluent communities.
你可能听说过金钱并不总能买到幸福。对于来自富裕家庭的孩子来说，这尤其正确，因为他们可能感受到必须成功、取得好成绩并成为模范儿童的压力。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，她正在教导自己的孩子如何在不依赖金钱的情况下获得幸福。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。苏尼尔·卢瑟是亚利桑那州立大学的心理学教授。她研究过贫困青少年以及受精神疾病影响的儿童和家庭的脆弱性与韧性。她最近的研究重点是富裕社区的儿童。
Welcome, Dr. Luther. Ah, thank you for having me. Is depression very common among children from affluent families? You know, how do these depression rates compare to children from lower-income families? What we found already is rates of about one and a half to two and a half times as high as national normative samples. Of problems like depressive symptoms, anxiety symptoms, and even higher rates of problems. higher rates of problems of substance use, that would be alcohol, marijuana, and even heart drugs.
欢迎您，卢瑟博士。啊，谢谢你邀请我。抑郁症在富裕家庭的孩子中很常见吗？你知道，这些抑郁症发病率与低收入家庭的孩子相比如何？我们发现，这些症状的发病率大约是全国常模样本的1.5到2.5倍。像抑郁症状、焦虑症状等问题，甚至在药物滥用方面——也就是酒精、大麻，甚至是硬性毒品——问题发生率更高。
Wow. So when you were studying this, was it a surprising finding to you? Oh, it was awfully surprising. Actually, I stumbled upon these findings quite by accident. My first study on upper-middle-class youth was conducted essentially to look for a comparison group for inner-city kids. And while doing this comparison, we found, much to my surprise, that the sort of the so-called privileged or rich kids were doing much more poorly, again, mostly on substance use,
哇。那么当你在研究这个问题时，这是一个让你感到惊讶的发现吗？哦，这非常令人惊讶。事实上，我完全是偶然发现了这些结果。我对中上层阶级青少年的第一次研究，本质上是为了寻找一个与内城孩子进行比较的群体。而在进行这种比较时，令我非常惊讶的是，我们发现所谓的特权阶层或富家子弟的情况要糟糕得多，同样，主要是在药物滥用方面，
but also in depression and anxiety. So that was way back in the late 90s, and since then we followed that trail and replicated these findings over and over again. What have you found to be the reason behind these high numbers? Can you describe the research a little bit more in detail on this area? Yes. People have a tendency to say, oh, it's the parents. And I cannot think of something that is more misguided than to pick on either the parents or the schools. There is not a single unitary factor that will explain all this. It is a problem that derives from multiple levels. Let's start with just American society and what our values are.
但也包括抑郁和焦虑。那是在90年代末，从那时起，我们沿着这条线索进行了多次重复验证。你认为这些高数字背后的原因是什么？你能更详细地描述一下这个领域的研究吗？是的。人们倾向于说，哦，都是父母的错。但我认为没有什么比指责父母或学校更误导人的了。没有单一的因素可以解释这一切。这是一个源于多个层面的问题。让我们从美国社会以及我们的价值观开始谈起。
More is better. Go ahead. The title of my last chapter, I can, therefore I must. If you can, therefore you must. Achieve more and move ahead. So this starts at the level of society. Then it goes into the schools. It goes into the universities.
越多越好。请继续。我最后一章的标题是：我能，所以我必须。如果你能，所以你必须。取得更多成就并不断前进。所以这始于社会层面。然后进入学校。再进入大学。
What is it that admissions people value in making their selections? It's all about accomplishments and achievements. So the bottom line is it is not just the family, it is not just the child, it is the culture we live in, the universities, the schools, everybody coming together to reinforce that one big message. If you can, therefore you must. Do not stop. So how does this relate to the problems of depression, substance, pressure to achieve? You see, if your sense of self-worth gets tied into how much you can accomplish, two things happen. One is if you don't accomplish, you feel small, inadequate, lousy, what have you. And the other is you live in a state of fear of not achieving.
招生人员在做选择时看重什么？全都是关于成就和功绩。所以底线是，这不仅仅是家庭的问题，也不仅仅是孩子的问题，而是我们所处的文化、大学、学校，所有人共同强化了那一个大信息。如果你能，所以你必须。不要停下来。那么这与抑郁、药物滥用、成就压力的问题有什么关系呢？你看，如果你的自我价值感与你能取得多少成就挂钩，就会发生两件事。一是如果你没有取得成就，你会感到渺小、无能、糟糕等等。另一件事是，你生活在一种对无法取得成就的恐惧状态中。
If I can tell myself I'm a good person because I'm a good mother, a good friend, that's one thing. If I tell myself I'm a good person to the degree that I get that mixed grant or I get famous or I get these accolades, I'm living in fear. These are things that are not as much in my control as are things like being a good mother or being a good friend. So living in this constant state of tension, fear, if I don't achieve, who will I be? Is something that puts us in a state of anxiety and the failures in a state of depression. To self-medicate these feelings of anxiety and depression, unfortunately, a lot of our kids are turning to drugs and alcohol, as are we their parents. Is your advice that affluent parents simply lower the pressures they put on their children?
如果我能告诉自己我是一个好人，因为我是一个好母亲、好朋友，那是一回事。如果我告诉自己，我是一个好人，程度取决于我是否获得了那笔混合拨款，或者我是否出名，或者我是否获得了这些荣誉，那我就是在恐惧中生活。这些事情不像做一个好母亲或好朋友那样在我的掌控之中。因此，生活在这种持续的紧张和恐惧状态中——如果我不成功，我会是谁？——这让我们处于焦虑状态，而失败则让我们处于抑郁状态。为了自我治疗这些焦虑和抑郁的感觉，不幸的是，我们的许多孩子开始转向毒品和酒精，就像我们这些父母一样。你的建议是富裕的父母应该简单地降低他们给孩子施加的压力吗？
Or how do they go about to balance the need? for success versus, you know, mental health. In terms of advice for parents, I'm thinking back on when we had first started doing in-depth research on families and poverty, right? Now, mothers in poverty living in inner city areas where there's a lot of violence and so on, they have to work extra hard to make sure that children do not hang out after dark in places that are dangerous. It almost becomes extra important for them to pay attention to this front.
或者他们该如何平衡对成功的需求与心理健康？关于给父母的建议，我回想起我们刚开始对贫困家庭进行深入研究的时候。在内城地区，暴力事件频发，贫困母亲们必须格外努力，确保孩子们在天黑后不会在危险的地方闲逛。对她们来说，关注这一方面变得格外重要。
In much the same way, we have to be. parents in upper middle class societies have to work extra hard at ensuring that our children have a balanced value system, that they are not all about who can I be, how far can I go at whatever cost, but they are equally, if not more, invested in, how can I be a decent kind person, invested in the good of humanity and not just myself. So to summarize that, just as the inner city parents must work. extra hard to keep their children physically safe and out of trouble with gangs, we in upper middle class white-collar families need to work extra hard to make sure our children do not get
同样地，我们必须……中上层社会的父母必须格外努力，确保我们的孩子拥有平衡的价值观，他们不仅仅关注“我能成为谁”、“我不惜一切代价能走多远”，而是同样甚至更投入于“我如何成为一个体面、善良的人”，投入于人类的福祉，而不仅仅是自己。总结一下，就像内城区的父母必须格外努力以确保孩子的人身安全并远离帮派麻烦一样，我们这些中上层白领家庭的父母需要格外努力，确保我们的孩子不会被
swept away in this feeling of, I must do more, and stay grounded more in decency, kindness, and true compassion, concern for humanity. And that in turn will affect their own well-being. Absolutely. There are more and more studies now saying if you are good and compassionate and kind, that this helps your own well-being. Altruism helps you feel better about yourself. There are studies showing psychological well-being is better. They're physiological studies that show this. So yes, doing for others makes you feel good.
这种“我必须做得更多”的感觉所淹没，并更多地扎根于体面、善良和真正的同情心，以及对人类的关怀。而这反过来会影响他们自己的幸福感。绝对是这样。现在有越来越多的研究表明，如果你善良、富有同情心，这有助于你自己的幸福。利他主义有助于你对自己感觉更好。有研究表明心理健康状况会更好。也有生理学研究证明了这一点。所以是的，为他人做事会让你感觉良好。
Well, that's one thing. And doing for others also, obviously, strengthens your connections with others. So just the sheer act of generosity of altruism is going to make you feel better yourself. And the FOIA, the second thing, is that you're going to strengthen and your relationships with the people for whom you are doing good. They will appreciate it.
嗯，这是一方面。而且为他人做事显然也加强了你与他人的联系。所以，仅仅是慷慨和利他主义的行为本身就会让你自己感觉更好。第二点是，你将加强与你所帮助的人之间的关系。他们会感激你的。
And there's another stronger social network, a link in your social network. What other behavioral mental health problems do you see among children and parents of more privileged families? Anything beyond depression, substance abuse? Yes, we have, in order, if I were to go in order, the problems that we've seen among upper middle class kids is starting with alcohol and drug use,
这会形成一个更强大的社交网络，是你社交网络中的一个环节。在更优越的家庭的孩子和父母中，你还看到了哪些其他的行为心理健康问题？除了抑郁和药物滥用之外还有什么吗？是的，如果我们按顺序排列，我们在中上层阶级孩子身上看到的问题，首先是酒精和药物使用，
depression and anxiety. Now here's one that really startled me. High levels of rule breaking. Now we're talking about random acts of delinquency. We found levels are comparable actually to levels in inner city settings. The only difference is the inner city kids are doing things like carrying a gun or getting into a fight and so on, which could potentially be in self-protection and gangs. Our upper middle class kids are doing things like stealing from a friend or stealing from a parent or defacing property, as I said, random acts of delinquency. And these rates are much higher, again, two to two and a half times as high as average rates in America. Then there is envy, particularly among our girls, levels of envy of peers are much higher than we find among inner-city girls or boys
抑郁和焦虑。现在有一个让我非常震惊的问题。高水平的违规行为。我们谈论的是随机的犯罪行为。我们发现其水平实际上与内城环境中的水平相当。唯一的区别是，内城区的孩子做的事情比如携带枪支或打架等等，这可能出于自我保护和帮派原因。我们的中上层阶级孩子做的事情比如从朋友那里偷东西，或者从父母那里偷东西，或者破坏财产，正如我所说，是随机的犯罪行为。这些比率要高得多，同样是美国平均水平的2到2.5倍。然后是嫉妒，特别是在我们的女孩中，对同龄人的嫉妒程度远高于我们在内城区女孩或男孩中发现的水平，
or upper-middle-class boys. For some reason, our girls are showing problems in multiple domains. So it's not just the depression, the anxiety, the typically female problems, but also the more typically male problems of drug and alcohol use and rule breaking. It's very troubling. How can parents teach their kids to have this balanced value system? And my answer almost invariably is, you know what, we really can't teach what we have to do as model. So I can tell my kids tell the cows come home, listen, be a good person.
或者是中上层阶级的男孩。出于某种原因，我们的女孩在多个领域都表现出问题。所以不仅仅是抑郁、焦虑这些典型的女性问题，还有更典型的男性问题，如药物和酒精使用以及违规行为。这非常令人担忧。父母如何教导孩子拥有这种平衡的价值观？我的回答几乎总是：你知道吗，我们真的无法教导，我们必须以身作则。我可以告诉我的孩子们，直到天荒地老，听着，要做一个好人。
But if I'm driving past people, cutting the grocery land, being inconsiderate to their teachers, to the household gardener or whatever, that's what the children pick up. They don't pick up what you say to them. They pick up what you do. The second thing is we need to be very conscious about our own values. See, it's very easy for us to say, no, I really want my child to be a good person. But take a step back and say, if your child did not make the starters in the basketball team, if the child did not get into the advanced reading group, might you, even with a slight raised eyebrow,
但如果我开车经过别人时插队，对他们的老师、家里的园丁或其他人表现得不体贴，那才是孩子们学到的东西。他们不会学你说的话。他们会学你做的事。第二件事是我们需要非常清醒地认识到我们自己的价值观。你看，我们很容易说，不，我真的希望我的孩子成为一个好人。但退一步想，如果你的孩子没有进入篮球队的首发阵容，如果孩子没有进入高级阅读小组，你是否会，即使只是微微挑起眉毛，
a slight gesture, be conveying, I'm disappointed? You see, we fall into this trap without realizing. it sometimes that we are conveying to them that I geez it's not quite as uh it's not quite as direct or blatant as saying oh my god you you've got five a is why the one be can be much more subtle and say just yeah well that's hopefully nice um and what did jimmy get or you know how did he do giving off impressions of competition exactly so we have but that means in turn that we need to look deep within ourselves see many of us and these upper middle class families we are hardworking, we've reached levels of professional accomplishment and so on, that mean a great
一个轻微的手势，传达出“我很失望”的信息？你看，我们有时会在不知不觉中陷入这个陷阱，向他们传达……天哪，这不像说“天哪，你得了五个A，为什么有一个B”那样直接或明显，它可能更微妙，只是说“哦，好吧，希望这很好”，或者“吉米得了多少分”或者“他表现如何”，从而给人一种竞争的印象。没错，所以这意味着我们需要深入审视自己。你看，我们中许多人，在这些中上层家庭中，我们努力工作，我们达到了职业成就的水平等等，这对我们意义重大。
deal to us. If I feel like my work, my career brings me such enormous gratification, somewhere subconsciously, otherwise I want my child to have a very successful career path, too, so that he or she can have the same gratification. That can lead us to, again, inadvertently doing and saying things that we don't mean to. Yes, it's lovely if my child has a PhD, but you know what? There are other things in life. As I often tell young people, including my own children, when they're applying to college, you'll get an education. It's all right.
如果我觉得我的工作、我的职业带给我巨大的满足感，在潜意识里，或者其他方面，我也希望我的孩子有非常成功的职业道路，这样他或她也能获得同样的满足感。这可能导致我们再次无意中做和说一些我们本意并非如此的事情。是的，如果我的孩子有博士学位当然很好，但你知道吗？生活中还有其他事情。正如我经常告诉年轻人的，包括我自己的孩子，当他们申请大学时，你会接受教育的。没关系。
You'll get an education. Life does not begin and end at being at the top. Great. Well, thank you, Dr. Luther. I appreciate you taking the time. Thank you so much. It was my pleasure. Thank you so much.
你会接受教育的。生活并不始于也不终于站在顶峰。太棒了。好吧，谢谢你，卢瑟博士。我很感激你抽出时间。非常感谢。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢。
To listen to more podcast episodes, please visit our website at speakingof psychology. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要收听更多播客剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》。谢谢。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。